we have to set the rumor straight on
Drake who was not arrested in Sweden
this week despite reports emerging on
social media yeah rumors emerged on
Thursday that Drake had been arrested by
local police at a Stockholm nightclub
however Drake's reps have since told The
Hollywood Reporter that this is not the
case and that he was in his hotel room
at the time now while it's unclear why
Drake is in Sweden at the moment right
his air Drake private jet was spotted
landing at a Swedish airport earlier
this week I mean I think the news of the
day is this airplane this is his this is
his plane this is his plane I've
actually never seen pictures of this
yeah I think it was from cargo Jed was
it was a gift as I remember
and I wonder how it is inside but I mean
if you have a jet like that why not go
to Stockholm and just have fun I agree I
just don't understand how you mess up
someone getting arrested isn't there
actually official papers to see if
someone was arrested or not like how
does a rumor like that start if it's not
true
do you think he was I don't know picked
up and then let go and released and I
don't know or maybe it's just a story so
we're talking about it the fact that he
is in Sweden and maybe we're talking
about a new project that he's doing in
Sweden that would be cool I mean that is
cool but Drake I hope you're okay I mean
don't do drugs kids he's probably like
having the signs of his life we're all
talking about this he's probably like
what are y'all talking about I don't
know I'm just here on my channel I'm
just enjoying my chest
I'd like to get on that jet that's cool
I know that is pretty cool maybe that's
the story we need to run next time is to
see the inside of his job oh wouldn't
that be great that would be fun I'd do
that story that'd be fun